hey what's up guys my name is luciano
welcome back to another
code review for those of you who are new
to this series it's basically a series
where i take a look at the code that you
guys send me
and i well i review it this is still one
of those like
raw series where i just haven't really
decided
what direction to take this in just
because a code review is such a general
thing in a way it's kind of difficult to
put it into the format of a video
because
a code review in real life as a software
engineer could take hours and
is very boring so it's called the code
review series but really it's the cherno
just talks about
code series anyway today i thought that
what we would do
is kind of simplify this thing so far
we've looked at
basically two little game engines you
could say we've had the
the 2d game engine made by like a 13
year old and the kind of step up to the
17 year old and today we've got a 19
year old so we're building
i can only go older and older with each
episode but today we have a 19 year old
computer science student who has just
made a little
pong clone so you know the game the
arcade game pong
he's made this for windows with the
objective of being making everything
from
scratch so this is this is interesting
because i think that this is a
i think this is actually like a
manageable size c plus project that you
guys could try and implement if you're
following along with my
c plus plus series then that's great
you're learning all about c plus and you
probably want some kind of project to
tackle but if you go to my game engine
series
a game engine is quite a large project
it's probably something i'm going to be
working on like for the rest of my life
so clearly it might be
a little bit of a step up this on the
other hand
is something that is realistic to
actually kind of finish
so i'm excited to dive into this is
something that potentially you guys
could take a look at yourselves and
hopefully
this and what we look at today will help
you out if you're in that boat but first
i want to mention that this video
is sponsored by skillshare for those of
you who still have somehow not heard of
skillshare even though they've been an
amazing sponsor for this channel
this entire year skillshare is an
amazing online learning community where
millions of creative and curious people
from all around the world come together
to learn
new skills it's the perfect platform to
pick up a new skill
especially if you find that you're short
of time and you want just bite-sized
concise lessons that you can follow
along
and learn something rapidly i love the
fact that skillshare has an incredible
selection
of really well put together classes on
pretty much any topic you could think of
anything from illustration to video
production to photography to editing
photos
to business and marketing and
productivity and art
lots and lots of art they've got you
covered no matter what you are
interested in and coming in at just
under ten dollars a month for an annual
subscription it's really easy to dive in
and get started but it's even easier
because for a limited time
skillshare is giving you guys free
skillshare premium
all you have to do is click the link in
the description below of this video and
sign up so definitely put that down time
to good use and try out skillshare for
free
using the link in description below
thank you again to skillshare for
sponsoring this video and all the other
videos this year it's been a very
skillshare year alright so without
further ado let's dive in and take a
look
at this little small pong game so here
is the github repository if we look
through this it's just a bare bones pong
clone made for windows from scratch you
can see we have like two paddles very a
very blurry looking ball
and it uses uh cmake right
so all we have to do is clone this
obviously i'm going to find
a directory and just type in git clone
there we go i didn't actually check to
see if it had any uh
sub modules or anything like that but i
guess we'll find out soon enough over
here inside the directory i'll make a
build directory
and then just run cmake to build the
project files okay and once we are done
with that let's go ahead and open the
solution file and we can see
what is up first thing i like to do is
just give this a quick build so ctrl
shift b to build the entire solution
and wait for this to compile make sure
it does compile step one
okay and then i will set the startup
project to be
le pong and we can take a look at
presumably the main file let's just run
this code see
uh if everything works properly first
okay so there we go we've got pong
um i'm not sure before you read the
instructions we'll space blast them to
start and then we have
up and down arrow keys for the right
paddle and then uh w
and s keys for the left paddle okay cool
so there we go that looks like pong to
me
i guess it works pretty well um
let's try and deliberately lose here and
it resets
okay pretty cool so i notice the
window's not resizable which is uh
unfortunate but that's pretty much as
simple as you can get
also i'm not not a huge fan of this
blurry light bulb thing
i don't know how this is rendered maybe
it's a texture maybe it's some fancy
shader or something i'm not sure
let's take a look at the code okay so
we have a main function we have a main
file that's really clean
i really like this i love looking at a
main file and it's not just cluttered
with
a bunch of code this person has not
written their code all in one file which
is fantastic
that in itself is a really good setup
for a larger project uh
pong could easily be written in one file
i probably wouldn't have too much of an
issue with it
but it's obviously nice to see something
like that let's naturally follow this to
maybe this header file and then we'll
take a look at this macro and some other
things
as well okay so in general this code
looks great using some kind of
documentation here that's even like a
return
kind of keyword i imagine if you hover
your mouse over this you can see that
visual studio will pick up
i guess this syntax and you can see that
like there's a special return thing and
it returns this text
so in in in other words the
documentation has been done really well
there's all this no except stuff which i
mean i'm not a huge fan of just
exceptions and the fact that
because of exceptions and there's you
know like no discard and there's all
these attributes surrounding
uh c plus plus and in general even you
know trying to write a
fully correct c plus data structure
these days in 2020 it's just
littered with so many keywords and so
many extra compiler like
um directives i guess and other things
and it's just i don't know i feel like
staples plus is getting a little bit
a little bit messy let's be honest but
anyway nonetheless they're here that's
fine
looks really clean i like the the names
the use of namespaces here and
the documentation as i mentioned um
everything looks really good
and this looks really clean which is
great it's a really good start so far
let's take a look at this macro and see
what it does
okay so this macro goes over here um
and we have this kind of if condition
then oh well this
this does assert or return
a certain return with a condition
and then the value so
this will return the value
so it runs the condition and if the
condition
fails it returns a value so in other
words
this will cause the main function to
return negative one
if init fails i'm not going to lie that
took me like a minute to work out
otherwise there's also this a certain
log function which i guess if the
condition is false
the condition the condition itself is
the thing that you run that's why
there's a semicolon here
otherwise uh it will log the message
that you want so
interesting little assertion macros um i
mean they don't really like
their recessions but they don't do they
don't break the debugger on a particular
line which
is personally something that i like and
i think in general that's what a session
macros do um so this this is definitely
interesting i don't think i've ever seen
anything like this before um
it's kind of a certain return situation
i mean i probably would have just
separated this out into like some kind
of a cert macro maybe
that would run this um but see the
the other problem with this is that to
me an assertion macro implies that it's
a debug only thing
right if you start wrapping your
recession macros uh
if you start wrapping important code in
the session macros to me that that says
that potentially
in release mode that gets nuked right
because
an asset is really like a debug thing um
you can have obviously release mode
assets and like verify or like there's a
bunch of other
like um i guess uh i was gonna say
stereotypes conventions you know
that um software uh developers
use but um yeah so in general
not a huge fan of this you know um init
returns a bull in
right so i would have just done
something like we'll uh
you know init or something like that
equals that and then if not init or
you know if error or you know you can
call this whatever you like
then maybe assert and return negative
one that to me just makes a lot more
sense than
wrapping all of that kind of in a macro
um but you know to each their own
okay so we what does initializing this
game do right
so we have a static here um we uh
that we initialize here we have game
lifetimes okay wow this code is really
nicely written um and i mean like my
style isn't to
to you know have like a little uh
comment here this person did mention
they're a computer science student
i can see that um i feel like this is
like the thing that they teach you
um in computer science i mean you know
it's kind of like one of those things
where like clean up game systems
cleans up the game's systems really
you know this is one of those things
that like you you the code is
self-documenting to a point right
inner game systems initialized game
systems cleans up games this is just
noise at this point you know
none of these comments need to exist
this makes perfect sense
um and i think that uh you know outside
of like a university assignment which i
don't know if this is or not but
outside of that it's just not necessary
to have anything like this because it's
it's the code is self-documenting this
is interesting though
we so we have um a static constant
expression lifetime
right which is a class holding the unit
and cleanup functions of any item
which have these kind of function
pointers right so this is a void
function that returns a bully and this
is a void function that returns
did i say a void function returns a ball
in i meant a function with no parameters
that returns a boolean
and this is a the same thing but a void
function
um you can pass these two in uh and then
i'm assuming it
gets added into some list which is
really interesting so i've seen
this kind of pattern i don't know what
it's called i never know what these
things are called but basically what
this
ends up looking like is a little array
of
pairs of you know like constructor
struct
constructor struct constructor struct
right so
i think you might know where i'm going
with this this is the great thing
about rai so resource acquisition is
initialization i really like that saying
but the point is
this is what objects and seatbelts do
they have a constructor they have a
destructor
i would have probably implemented this
with classes instead of having loose
functions like this this is a very c
style way of writing c plus anywhere
because you can see that i mean i
haven't seen a single class yet
which is fine no sorry that's a lie
lifetime is a class but you get what i'm
trying to say
right um and you know having function
pointers here
totally fine code um i i wouldn't look
at this and think that it's not great
code or anything
um it actually looks kind of advanced to
me to be honest
uh i wouldn't i wouldn't expect code
like this from a
first year i don't know if this person
is in their first year but they are 19.
um so this is like a good job i guess so
far but yeah some of these things
again just just some just personal
preference i would probably use like a
class because that implicitly has that
construction destruction to it
if you really want to tie it to that um
but then again
you know if you look at what lifetime
does
lifetime has its own kind of a knit and
clean up function as well that wraps
these and they are constant expressions
so
yeah it's a really interesting uh way of
writing this as well
anyway i'm getting a little bit ahead of
this so let's uh go back to in it and
see what hap what actually happens so
again a certain return value so it
returns false
if that's false interesting but
the problem is this is a nightmare to
debug right if i want to see what
happens putting a break point here
trying to debug macros
not really that very not really nice
right if you just had something like
this right um if blah blah return false
really easy right you put a little break
point you can hit
like f10 oh it's on this line i guess
i'm returning false
super easy super nice so i much i would
take this
any day over this right um so initialize
we try and emit items here
and this is what i mean right so there's
a constant array reference of lifetimes
and those lifetimes contain those
function pointers that call in it so
we can literally go through all of them
and call init and basically what ends up
happening is for these lifetimes for
example we call the unit functions for
all of these
um and you know there's probably like a
matching pair of that
for these shutdown functions which are
cleanup functions so that's kind of
interesting haven't seen that in a while
um same with this right we have these
init functions these are our state
lifetimes
that's what we're kind of iterating
iterating over and calling each of these
functions because these are in fact
function pointers which of course you
know are these functions right
and so that we can we can kind of call
them in a way dynamically it's almost
like
adding like a registry of of startup and
shutdown functions
so that's pretty cool actually um i'm
enjoying this code so far
so try init items obviously that's what
that's what that does um if succeeded is
false then
they clean up items starting from i
guess the ones that we got up to so
we basically have this list of things to
initialize and then as soon as we run
into an error we
roll that back um so that's kind of
interesting kind of unnecessary
if it if succeeded is like this is a
cool pattern for the sake of having it
but for the sake of the game it's like
well succeeded we failed to initialize
the window just shut down the app
like immediately who cares about
cleaning anything up we don't need to
clean anything up
operating system will reclaim the memory
like that be way better than trying to
roll back everything
this is good code though this is good
code though i'm just talking for more of
a practical sense
all right um so this is this is cool
this is nice this is one of those things
that you would
you would kind of show to a university
professor and be like hey
i know what's up i know what i'm doing
so this is good all right
um uh blah blah blah okay i'm not gonna
like
think about that too much so far from a
systems programming point of view this
is pretty nice code
okay what does run do this is the main
game loop so again we have that so a
return
pattern thing running is set to true
um it's a static okay call on begin run
so this is what actually shows the
window says resizable to false
log contact specifications so this just
logs the opengl version and everything
um reset game state okay
so this what is this is this a
ball dot reset okay so you've added
reset functions to every object okay
i wouldn't do this what i would do
instead is simply recreate those objects
right so you have a ball a ball in
memory right what is a ball in memory
ball and memory is a game object that
hasn't moved direction and move speed a
position
probably some other stuff right that
memory is fine that's your ball
as soon as you wrap up the ball or you
want to reset
you clear that ball from memory and you
re-initialize it with a fresh ball
that is by far the best way of doing
this
now if we're talking about massive heap
allocations and
more complex things of course that's not
always ideally the way to do this but
the thing is every time you add a new
parameter to your ball
or to your game object you have to add
it to that reset function
if you don't then that's a problem right
maybe game object i haven't looked yet
but maybe your game object or whatever
you called it
maybe that has its own reset function
that's virtual and then you call that
base function from your override
of that function that cleans up all
specific things
it's it's a little bit of a mess and
it's it's
just really annoying to have to go to
that reset function and
keep adding keep adding variables that
need to be reset
and the other question is what do they
get reset to
maybe the speed should be one by default
not zero right because zero means it
doesn't move at all or something like
that
right that's super annoying as well so
if you just have a ball that gets
constructed with a speed of one done
right just stomp the ball with a fresh
ball and
obviously the way that you would do that
um if we go here reset game state
right is this ball you know just ball
equals ball
right and then i don't know if that
needs parameters i don't even know how
it gets created in the first place um
let's look at this uh flow rate yeah
actually that's a good point what
creates a ball
let's quickly try and track down that
constructor
um here it is
it's a static thing right so this you
know just recreate the ball
like that easy right recreate them with
these parameters and you're done
it's also really nice to have it in a
particular place now in this in this
case
these are clearly static constant
expressions if they're static constant
expressions
why are they in the pong class these are
clearly
the bull radius is clearly a ball thing
so is ball program which i assume is a
shader
program id right this stuff is both
specific so in a way you could just move
it to the bull class have them be
initialized with these variables and
have a default constructor
that you can then simply call in
keep losing everything um you can simply
call
by uh
learn to navigate code channel um by
just doing that
right so that's what i would do instead
of having a reset function for every
game object just because that's really
annoying to maintain
okay um yeah and in general don't be
afraid to
reconstruct objects right a little stack
allocation like this
walk in the park right not not even
something to worry about
um same with the paddles okay so that's
that um playing fault okay let's go back
to
uh where were we before this we were in
position paddles on terrain
so again you know this system this this
is like a bit of a reset thing where
does it go or it goes a keyboard or
offset or whatever that's
cons that's 50. it's always 50. right
just initialize a paddle at that
position maybe
um and then that way you can like
recreate it or you can just in general
have a function called create paddles
then we'll just always set it to that
instead of just having to override these
kind of static objects
so that's something that i would have um
all right let's go back to
here and then we get into um okay we see
the random
number generator using s rand wouldn't
recommend doing that in
because that's like a very c style way
of generating generating random numbers
um
the random number generating c plus plus
is a lot better um
i think if you if you i'll link a video
up there that's me making a game in an
hour that's where i used the cpl plus
random generator if you're interested
because it will get you higher quality
random numbers
believe me that's a thing okay um
and that's for future you know pong is
going to be fine with srand
it's going to be fine um okay that's
that's our on begin run function
uh then we uh you know this is true so
we go to on update on render
i love this separation right it's good
that you don't just have
you know or actually i was going to say
i love that separation
on update and render needs to be two
distinct things
whether or not they have to be two
distinct functions is up to you it's
fine to have a function called on update
that does
updating and rendering as long as you're
not kind of doing it within one function
you're not doing kind of
update balls position render ball update
enemies position render
enemy you don't want to do that right
because that that's gonna mess you
up um you need to update all of your
state process that and then do the
rendering usually at the end
um so it's good to see this kind of
separation again it doesn't have to be
two functions
in hazel we usually have just one on
update function that will update
everything and then you can submit stuff
to the render queue for rendering and
doing other stuff like that uh okay so
on update
we'll get the time delta okay don't like
this
i don't like doing this um so we have
these constants
so time get happens this is a very kind
of global approach to this
um it's it's a lot i think it's a lot
easier to understand
if inside here you calculate delta
and you just pass in the time step right
because
that way um there's no ambiguity to like
how it gets calculated and having to
like you know have this static
last time in here and you know not
really knowing how everything flows
um it's just usually just a lot easier
to calculate and then pass it in
and that way the burden of calling this
function does never falls on on update i
understand that you've probably got on
update
yes so you've got one on update function
for your application and then you call
all of these with delta
maybe call this one with that that delta
as well
and that way everything is really nicely
organized because this is an update
function and an update function always
has a delta
just a bit of a code thing so how do we
update the ball
position plus equals move direction
times move speed times delta
interesting um now this is fine
i just don't like the idea of delta
being in these parentheses
because delta is you should
be moving by this is actually what it
should be
right this makes a lot more sense i'm
moving by this amount
but i need to only move this much
because that's how much time has passed
right so it's kind of like you have your
move speed calculated
in like meters per second we'll say and
then the times delta
is what actually makes it be per second
right so i don't really like the other
way
that you wrote it this is this is
technically makes more sense right
um update with delta and window size
super weird to take in window sizes
into like an update function right you
should definitely have a global way
see in this case you should use a global
global thing right you should have a
global way to retrieve the window size
you have one window that's never going
to change you're not going to have two
pong windows and even if you do you can
think of something then right you're
going to have a global window so have
some kind of static window class or
static application class that can get
you the window size
right taking it into here is a little
bit weird um
game object update so i guess here
you're calling the root or the uh
the base class which just does that
which is fine
collide with terrain um
clyde's top clyde's bottom so the
terrain is just the the bounds of the
window
um and then if it does collide
um i i would say maybe don't use auto
everywhere by the way i've noticed this
a little bit
um and by a little bit i mean in most
places to be honest now that i'm looking
at it
this is a bullying right
just just write bull it's the same
amount of characters
and it's just so much more readable
right
so definitely do that um that
yeah definitely have a bull here whether
or not this has to be constant as well
this is
one of those things where you've just
got like and this is well this is
clearly a float just just write flow
you know it's not not that difficult if
you have these huge class names like i
get it you know
vector 2i maybe i would write auto
instead of that
not that's a huge class name but you
know boolean and float and
keep your primitive types mostly mostly
just use them
um and again with this const situation i
don't know i just feel like this is just
so
it just pollutes your code so much this
is gonna get you the same result right
um making this cons not making this
const
i don't think it's gonna make any
difference in code generation to be
honest if it does that's
super weird to me um so it should be
okay
um all right uh same with this right
like again
it's fine if you if you feel safer with
const and you like that and it
enforces you to make sure that that's
something that you're definitely not
changing
leave it but the auto thing the auto
thing has to go
um okay so let's collide with terrain
collide with terrain
well okay so we're here yep okay and
that's your paddle update okay
in general pretty good now um uh how
long have i been recording for
good thing i checked because this camera
shuts down after 30 minutes of recording
and i was like 29 minutes 11 seconds
um okay so i before we wrap this up i
want to take a quick look at your
rendering in general though so far
this is really nice code it's really
it's quite easy to read
it uses some cool advanced things that's
great i think that if someone who is
potentially looking to hire you
looked through this code they would be
mostly happy they would be like oh cool
this person has demonstrated quite a bit
and also it's just really neat and it's
really well organized
and i'm i'm loving that so this is great
um
okay so paddle make pedal fragment
shader obviously this is a game not an
engine so
it's fine that this doesn't have like
some kind of shader class or
renderer class and all of that stuff
it's good to see it like this it does
have a graphics file which we might
look into in a minute but let's take a
look at this i guess
just because we're naturally here um
so uh make paddle fragment shaders so
again
we have like some code here that
literally just
um shades the thread color like this
here's a little tip you can remove those
extra ones
for white um that's fine and then let's
see where that gets called because i'm
actually kind of interested in that
so um in paddle programs this is a
paddle program create
a program with wind size uniform very
interesting function and i guess this
this loads the window
size uniform the provided shaders
are then destroyed that um that i think
that
that that definitely sounds weird but
i'm
sure you probably mean these for these
yeah the unit because when in opengl
when you like create a shader program
you wind up with a program but the
individual shaders can kind of be
removed they're kind of like
intermediate files like dot or
dot obj files when you're compiling with
visual studio you don't really need the
intermediate files once you have the exe
once you have the program at the end of
the day but this just sounds funny um
all right cool so make a quadratic
shader and then obviously this is the
function that we're interested in
um i noticed that like in a lot of these
cases you're not using header files for
like little
uh function declarations i imagine
that's probably because
they're just going to be tied to this
file um but i will say that
having them all over your code like this
is not
that great and i don't know if this
necessarily would
would be good if you split it up into
multiple files or not
but i don't like scrolling through this
code and every now and then seeing like
a declaration rather than a definition
i think that's just a little bit messy
uh in an otherwise very clean project
okay
so create program from shaders i don't
think i want to look at this um it's
interesting that you have these gl
namespace things i'm not sure what's
going on here so what is this
so you have your own little wrapper for
opengl functions
um oh are you retrieving them yourself
that's the question
hey you are that's kind of cool i guess
you did say from scratch
okay well done so um this uh
code is actually loading
the required opengl functions from
um the driver instead of actually
uh you know using something like glad or
glue or any other libraries that do that
for you and then also i'm noticing
obviously in this gl
um thing uh that there's yeah there's
always pixel format stuff so we've got
win32 api code that's actually creating
the window so we're not using anything
like glw
um yeah so that's pretty cool um i guess
you know this really is from scratch
um it's very windows it's windows only
obviously
um it's going to be hard to bring that
out to other platforms i mean you'll
probably have to rewrite this file per
platform which is why i'm using
something like glfw
and glad is good but obviously this is
intended to be an exercise
and for that well done i don't think
i've ever done this before
definitely you know done win32 api stuff
before but i've never
actually loaded my own open gel
functions just because there's so many
of them
i'm likely going to need all of them and
glad just does everything for me in the
exact same way that i would do it so
basically no reason to do that but
obviously as an educational point of
view this is cool because you're
actually doing everything yourself
which is um great okay so that's the
whole gl thing let's
look at the graphics class as well um
and again this is like initializing
we're loading uh the dll file and then
dynamically
probably you know loading all the
function pointers to all of those and
this is freeing them in cleanup
and create shader from source
just compiling shader stuff um yeah
uh oh actually one last thing that i
might look at is
the ball so how is the ball
ah it is some cool shader thing i
thought it was i was so sure it was a
texture
that's actually really funny so there
you go you got a little simple glow so
we've got the normal
the norm norm texture position
which is impossible to see what it is
because i don't know what the
where the vertex shader is let's go
let's try and find that
make textured quad vertex shader and
then this is just the
uh the texture coordinates so do not
call them texture position that
that's um no idea what that is the only
reason i suspect it's a vertex
it's a texture coordinate is because
it's in location one i guess and it's an
attribute and it's a vector
um in fact i probably should verify that
that's the case um
yeah it is right so these are texture
coordinates so from zero
zero one one zero okay all that stuff
right so
um i would call them texture coordinates
for sure
um and then don't even get me started on
graphics and rendering um
so uh all this stuff so we we have the
times two minus one right so
this um times too much fun this is
interesting so this is this basically
maps our texture corners
into a negative one to one space instead
of zero to one
um and then we just do a little dot
product between the texture position
oh with itself sure so square distance
to center this just squares it
essentially
um and then we do one minus uh square
distance to center so by doing this what
this actually does is make makes it so
that the middle of the screen is zero
zero um and then or the middle of the
geometry we're drawing i should say
because that's what has the texture
coordinates is zero zero and then
the left side is negative one right side
is positive one and same with bottom and
um top respectively so and then we have
an intensity one minus square distance
center a little bit of a fall off here
some attenuation and then that's our
intensity
um in all channels including the alpha
channel so that's kind of cool real cool
little glow
um and uh
do collide with don't mind if i do
um so this is uh yeah just some
collision code and i expect this is just
abb
stuff it could be a little uh circle to
box collision i've lost everything as
usual
where's my do collide function um
it is yep so we have a little radius of
the thing and then we just
check the magnitude and see if it's
correct so that's good because the ball
is in fact a circle and we should be
using that kind of collision for that
um and that's it yeah
so in general um i don't know what else
there is to say
i'm just going to go through everything
make sure that i haven't missed anything
huge but i don't think i have
cool we've got a proper timer with query
performance counter that's also nice to
see
um yeah
and on our window creation function i'm
not going to go over this stuff but
obviously
win32 api code instead of glw or
whatever and you guys can see that
it's like 250 lines of code it's not a
huge deal to create your own window
it's just that um you know obviously
something like gfw makes it a lot easier
for you and also
does all the platform implementations
for you macos and linux as well
not just windows so in general that's
why people use that but
windows itself is not particularly
difficult to set up
um okay that's it
so in summary i enjoyed this code i
think it's written in a very neat way
there are obviously some things that i
would change a little bit and i did
mention them
but in general well done um this is
really good i think that if a recruiter
or some kind of person you know who was
looking to hire your work with you
looked at this code they would mostly be
quite impressed with your code style
um and that that's great and also you've
obviously shown that you can write stuff
from scratch and
you're not overly reliant on libraries
which again from a practical point of
view
is unnecessary but from a um
you know look at me this is what i'm
capable of point of view is
perfect so well done i hope to see much
more code like this
in the future hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please don't forget to
hit the like button what did you think
of this code
did you disagree with me with anything i
said would you add any other stuff drop
it in the comments below let's have a
nice discussion don't forget if you want
to submit your code for a code review i
do have an email address in the
description below channel review
gmail.com feel free to send me any kind
of code that you want me to review
doesn't have to be c
plus doesn't have to be um i haven't
looked at anything that's not c
plus yet i realize that but doesn't have
a pc plus plus doesn't have to be a game
or game related or whatever
i'll i usually just pick the projects
based on what i think
how i think they will do for videos and
how helpful they will be to the
community obviously my channel is built
around simple sports and game related
stuff so
that's why i'm picking a lot of this
stuff but i'm not not not just kind of
tied into that
and i mean there are like hundreds of
emails in my inbox so
i might not get to you but it's always
worth a shot to submit it and
if it's really exciting and interesting
then of course i will try my best to
take a look at it thank you guys for
watching don't forget that you can check
out the link in description below to get
your free
trial for skillshare premium and i will
see you guys next time
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
foreign